well I love the tone of the film the
ghosts are machine because there's not
really an angry sort of protest message
to it it's done in a very I don't want
to say soft but I'm not able to come up
with a better word right now but it's
it's done in a very artful soft way that
really does make you look at it in a way
that doesn't beat you over the head did
you experience compassion fatigue that's
my new favorite word right now I like
that well just part of why I was drawn
to Joanne and ask joanne to be the
protagonist in the movie is because
she's very radiant and hopeful and
charismatic and and I didn't you know I
wanted that positive message leading the
the experience in the movie rather than
something that was quite sort of heavy
because the subject is so heavy there's
so much gravity to it it's quite
gruesome and horrifying when you really
start unpacking it and realizing this
the staggering statistics and the the
violence that is so inherent in these
industries it's so difficult and of
course people don't want to watch that
so it was all about trying to figure out
the right approach the right tone and
also I think using Joanna's that entry
point the audience can experience oh
that's what an animal rights activist
looks like that's what she that's what
it feels like she's she has these
special amazing friendly and
affectionate relationships with all
these animals that she meets she loves
them she has empathy for them and and I
like people and you love people and you
love the environment so you know I think
when I first came to start figuring out
what what what's the story what's the
angle for this movie it was at a point
where I really was quite aware of the
challenge of making this film just the
inherent sort of built-in challenge of
understanding the social resistance out
there about this subject and that people
can within any movement can sort of
become so they live sort of like they're
in bubbles and they lose perspective and
and I was determined to not lose that
perspective and to remain somewhat
critical so that like what I'm doing
when I'm at a Q&A after the film my
answer is just instinctively or for the
person in the audience that doesn't
maybe understand or hasn't really
considered any of this yet I'd rather
speak to that person than to all my
friends in the room not I mean no
offense to my friends I guess they're
awesome but I would rather try to reach
someone that hasn't that sort of is on
the other side of the glass who maybe
cares but doesn't really get that this
is morally significant and that we it's
a collective problem and that we should
all care so that's really my goal with
the film and and all of our goal like
everyone that worked on it you know
there wasn't it wasn't just like a crew
that consisted of vegans yessir there
was a whole range of different types of
people that that worked on this film I
wanted to work with the most talented
people that were very sensitive and open
and everyone was impacted everyone had
their own journey and I think that that
says something you know about the
subject matter that we all have a
journey with it
you